[Musik]
was haben lisa simpson karl lauterbach
und bill gates gemeinsam sie gelten als
nazi und was zeichnet märz aus man
definiert sie mit hilfe von stereotypen
märz tragen hornbrillen sind unsozial
und ernähren sich von tiefkühlpizza und
intellektuelle überflieger und technik
enthusiasten
nerds sind konformistischen sind
nonkonformistisch märz sind irgendwie
maschinen haft quasi menschgewordene
computer nerds sind genial und verfügen
über eine und domestizierte kreativität
keine dieser aussagen ist ganz falsch
und keine ist nur für sich genommen
vollkommen richtig das was einen nerd
ausmacht hat sich mit den jahren
verändert die kulturwissenschaftlerin
anne-kathrin kohout hat eine pop kultur
geschichte über den nerd geschrieben
darin rekapituliert sie dessen
entwicklung von den 50er jahren als er
noch eine holzschnittartige streber war
bis heute da seine konturen immer
unschärfer werden mein name ist khan
schwanke ich bin in unserem feld und für
die neuen sachbücher zuständig und darf
anne-kathrin kohout im heutigen faz
bücher podcast begrüßen hallo frau carla
schwenke wie wird man eigentlich zum
nerd entscheidet man sich dafür oder
unterläuft ein dass er so ein gängiges
negativ ist eigentlich dass es einem er
unterläuft zum also dass man quasi nicht
nur werden kann sondern es ja per einer
irgendwie gearteten auserwähltheit ist
insofern würde ich sagen herrschte
anderen bevor das man um einen nerd zu
sein vielleicht bestimmte talente
braucht oder ein bestimmtes mindset
braucht und vielleicht auch eine
bestimmte sozialisation braucht können
sie das spezifizieren was das für
talente sind oder was das für ein
mindset ist ja das ändert sich
eigentlich immer unter verschiedenen
gesellschaftlichen bedingungen
ich würde sagen dass wir heute wenn wir
von nerd sprechen sehr breiten begriff
haben das heißt die art der begabung die
man braucht um sich selbst nur zu nennen
ist eigentlich fast irrelevant geworden
also es gibt zum beispiel
fitness studios die sich sport nennen
also erreicht quasi die sportliche
betätigung oder überdurchschnittliche
sportliche betätigung schon aus um
diesen begriff für sich zu verwenden
aber das war natürlich nicht immer so
ich denke was noch stark eigentlichen
unsere heutige
betrachtungsweise des monats mit hinein
fließt ist dass er sehr stark mit
technik affinität zum beispiel verbunden
ist und ja da braucht es natürlich
bestimmte kenntnisse bestimmte
fähigkeiten oder begabungen in diesem
bereich genau vielleicht gehen wir mal
an den anfang ihres buchs ist es ja eine
pop kultur geschichte und sie sagen
immer wieder der nerd soll eine sozial
figur was ist eigentlich eine sozial
figur und wie entsteht sie ja das ist ja
ein thema das mir sehr wichtig ist weil
mich eigentlich zwei fragen gleichzeitig
beschäftigt haben als ich dieses thema
gefunden habe oder für mich auch
erfahrene habe um die erste frage war
erstmal so wäre es ein nerd also
wirklich eine ganz klar
kulturhistorische frage wer war zu
bestimmten zeiten oder werden sprach zu
bestimmten zeiten dieser figuren
bezeichnung und eine andere frage die da
eigentlich voraus geht ist aber was ist
ein rad und das bezieht sich vielleicht
so ein bisschen auf den ontologischen
status das heißt es ist eine figur
einfach nur als literarische figur die
man aus filmen kennt oder serien also
jemand wie faust oder routers oder so
ist der stereotyp ja also so was wie der
gangster oder die diva oder ist der nerd
nicht irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr
als all das und ich hörte die frage mit
ja er ist noch ein bisschen mehr als all
das und habe mehr das konzept der sozial
figur es vielleicht schon zu viel gesagt
weil das ist noch nicht wirklich konzept
realisiert ist aber ich habe mit dem
begriff der sozial figur gewählt weil er
zumindest bislang in der soziologischen
forschung etwas bezeichnet was mir sehr
wichtig erscheint und zwar eine gewisse
zeit spezifik also ein sozial figur ist
sehr eng sozusagen verbunden mit ganz
konkreten historischen
ereignissen mit
veränderungen gesellschaftlicher art mit
krisen erfahrungen auch und die sozial
figur ist immer eine mit der dann
bestimmte wünsche und ängste auf
verschiedene themen ausgetragen werden
und für mich ist der note 1 das sozial
figur und genau wie sozial figur kann
sich auch verändern sie können aber auch
verschwinden und ich denke der nerd ist
eine sozial figur geworden zusammen mit
den technik des kurden in den 80er und
90er jahren und ist auch immer noch eine
sozial figur allerdings bin ich mir
nicht so sicher wie lange noch sie haben
gerade einige nerds genannt aus der
kulturgeschichte
müsste man eigentlich bei der analyse
des phänomens unterscheiden zwischen
nerds in sagen wir filmen und nerds im
richtigen leben also ist der nerd als
ästhetische figur mehr als nur der
irgendwie metaphorisch verschobene
realen hört oder ist das ästhetische
hier vielleicht sogar die voraussetzung
für die entstehung dieses typus in der
wirklichkeit ja was zuerst da war kann
man glaube ich nicht beantworten
das ist eine ganz typische in der frage
aber es gibt also diese unterscheidung
macht natürlich gedanklich erst mal sind
es gibt nur in
ästhetischer literarische art in serien
filmen romanen und so weiter auf der
einen seite auf der anderen seite gibt
es immer auch eben historische personen
die diese figur verkörpern oder ja die
nerd genannt werden oder so und was ich
auf jeden fall was mir wichtig war zu
zeigen auch in meinem buch ist dass es
eine permanente wechselwirkungen gibt
also es gibt ja erst mal vielleicht die
literarische figur und diese wird
angewandt auf bestimmte historische
figuren wie zb konkrete computer
pioniere wie bill gates oder steve jobs
und so weiter und die verkörperung
sozusagen durch diese realen nerds in
anführungszeichen die verändert dann
aber auch wieder die figur also die
sozial figur und gibt ihr eine neue
facette oder lässt vielleicht andere
facetten dieser figur wieder
verschwinden also es ist eigentlich
immer so ein ganz enger austausch auch
zwischen figur und verkörperungen und
man kann jetzt nicht so richtig sagen
eigentlich was zuerst aber man keines
gedanklichen durchaus trennen haben sie
bei ihrer recherche so etwas wie ein uhr
nerd ausgemacht in literatur oder film
der irgendwie ganz prototypisch
funktioniert
also das schwierige eigentlich bei einer
erforschung jeder art von figuren ist da
gerade auch sozial figuren ist dass es
einerseits den begriff gibt ja begriff
nerd den kann man ganz klar irgendwie
begriffs geschichtlich erforschen und da
kann man ganz eindeutig sagen dass das
in die 50er jahre des letzten
jahrhunderts zurück zu verorten ist da
findet man in journalistischen artikeln
über die jugendsprache
genau also darf da kommt der begriff
dann erstmals auf und es wird so gezeigt
genau dass er eben also was man früher
als gouvernante nennt man heute hört
also das ist relativ klar zu verorten
was die figur also in ihren
charakteristika in ihren
jahren auch biografische narrativen usw
betrifft da würde ich sagen kann man
jetzt nicht so klar eine uhr figur
ausmachen also viele negative und
charakteristika die der nerd eigentlich
transportiert sind kulturgeschichtlich
sehr viel älter also reichen zurück in
andere auch figuren die es früher schon
gegeben hat wie der verrückte professor
zum beispiel oder auch das genie ist
auch so eine wichtige vielleicht voller
figur also man das ist so eine art auch
also es verbindet verbinden sich so
bestimmte grundtypen auch mit der figur
die natürlich kulturhistorisch ja ich
sag das jetzt mal einfach so immer schon
existiert haben aber natürlich daneben
zeit spezifisch immer noch mal genau
ausgestaltet worden war dann der
philister wie eine romantik aufs korn
genommen wurde so eine art of honor
lettres
also für mich war es eine erforschung
dieser sehr interessant zu sehen dass
der nerd aus dem square also dem spießer
dem mann klar in unserem kulturkreis er
vielleicht philister genannt hat und
deswegen beschreibe ich auch diese
figuren mein buch relativ ausführlich
sehr interessant und auch auf eine art
überraschen weil wir eigentlich mit dem
nerd etwas verbinden das also eine figur
verbinden die er am rande der
gesellschaft steht die eigentlich ihr
eine außenseiter figur ist und keine die
sozusagen teil dieser ja des zentrums
der gesellschaft enorm gesellschaft ist
wie vielleicht eher spießer der immer
auch transportiert ja eben die gängigen
vorherrschenden werte und ansichten über
zu
genau darzustellen und nichtsdestotrotz
ja ist diese herkunft relativ eindeutig
auszumachen und insofern kann man sagen
denn dort hat auch immer noch ein
bisschen was vom spießer behalten oder
eben auch vom philister behalten ich
würde sagen vor allem eigentlich auch
konservative werte beziehungsweise ist
der nerd nie eine figur die konservative
werte ablehnt es ist vielleicht eine
figur der diese werte abgesprochen
werden aber ja genau ist selbst keine
sozusagen
progressive figur oder keine
oppositionelle figur das ist glaube ich
relativ wichtig auch noch mal um sich zu
verdeutlichen dass der nerd ja durchaus
eben seine wurzeln im spießer oder eben
in wildes da hat sie schreiben dass die
anfänge des nerds zumindest im film in
amerika bei mti movie zu finden sind
welche rolle spielte er denn da und
warum ist er offensichtlich an
jugendliche gebunden ja also im team
format ist würde ich sagen dass der typ
dessen
entstanden also dieser teenager der ja
irgendwie so gar nicht zu diesen
populären figuren passt ja eigentlich
das gegenteil dieser populären figuren
ist und ich würde sagen dass mit diesem
timo wie vor man hat sich ja etwas
außenentwicklung aus die sie vielleicht
zu fallen und ich gegeben hat nämlich
dass überhaupt so etwas wie eine art von
jugendkultur
anfang des letzten jahrhunderts
aufgekommen dass und bei der sag ich mal
ein nerd in der anfangszeit ich hab ihm
gesagt er so der spießer und die
gegenfigur zu hört also auch das ist
immer wichtig wenn man so figuren
betrachtet also in welchen
figurenkonstellationen tauchen sie auf
und die gegend figur war ganz lange der
rebell
und das sieht man zum beispiel in so
frühen team movies wie laptops mit james
dean in der hauptrolle und das ändert
sich dann eben in den 70er 80er jahren
und dem team wir sind ihm sehr ihn die
wir glaube ich alle vor augen haben wenn
man diesen begriff irgendwie verwendet
dort wird ja dann hört dann zur
gegenfigur eigentlich des sportlers es
genau auf der männlichen seite oder das
ziel die das auf der weiblichen seite
also zu so einer
unpopulären figur gegenüber dem
populären figuren also was ich auf jeden
fall
sei es was man sehr gut zeigen kann
finde ich ist das in diesem team movie
formaten der nerd immer für gewissen
anti intellektualismus steht also was
vielleicht vorher außerhalb des team
movie formats schon im verrückten
professor zum beispiel zur darstellung
gekommen ist findet man dann im team
movie format und am beispiel des nerds
jahr genau in diesen serien und filmen
und also ich glaube das ist so eine
wichtige funktion der neuen figur in
diesem genau in diesen serien und auch
da vielleicht noch mal zu betonen also
am anfang in dieser zeit siebzigerjahre
team movistar der nerd auch noch keine
figur die jetzt besonders mit technik
oder damit computer technologie
verbunden war also es war wirklich erst
mal eine figur ist unpopulären das anti
intellektuellen auch also eine figur die
natürlich erst mal für
überdurchschnittliches intellekt stand
gegenüber eben diesen sehr körperlichen
figuren mit dem sportler der chili darin
und natürlich in der negativen
darstellungsweise dann auch immer
sozusagen gleichzeitig die aversionen
demgegenüber mit transportiert hat war
der nerd in dieser funktion auch ein
bischen sympathie träger also sollte der
zuschauer mit ihm mitfühlen oder war er
wirklich nur zielscheibe von hohn und
spott
also sehr oft wird eigentlich also wenn
man sich text über den nördlichen liest
oder auch bücher die es gibt
wird das immer so ein bisschen
stark diese tendenz heraufbeschworen ja
der nerd also erst wer also diese
wahnsinnig negative figur keiner wollte
sich damit identifizieren und dann gab
es eben diesem image wandel und diese
tendenz die sich durchaus auch weil man
muss schon sagen was damit eigentlich
immer schon auch eine schillernde figur
war ich glaube auch dass jede sozial
figur schillernd es war immer positive
und negative seiten sozusagen zur
anschauung auch kommen sollen und also
faktisch kann man auch sagen dass sich
also es gibt diverse studien dazu dass
ich wenn man teenager gefragt hat mit
welchen figuren sie sich in den serien
und filmen identifizieren dann haben
sich die meisten wirklich auch mit
identifiziert also es wäre glaube ich ja
es wäre wahrscheinlich ein riesiges
trauma entstanden wäre also der noch gar
keine sympathiefigur gewesen also auch
damals ja verdanken wir natürlich damit
auch ja etwas sympathisches aber
trotzdem war es jetzt nicht in dem sinne
ein role model für
junge menschen oder auch später dann
vielleicht ältere menschen also man
wollte natürlich nicht unbedingt so sein
wie der nerd aber natürlich war es
trotzdem eine figur die
repräsentativ war für viele menschen und
bestimmte auch grundcharakter
charakteristika viel realer personen in
sich vereint hat sie haben gerade noch
den anti intellektualismus erwähnte er
gerade in amerika ab den 50er jahren
konjunktur hatte und den jerry lewis
film the hottie professor von 0 63 wie
funktioniert das in dem film genau also
wie funktioniert das meinetwegen über
garderobe über make up über mimik und
und so fort also es geht glaube ich also
ich weiß gar nicht wie bekannte nati
professor in deutschland ist also ich
kannte den film tatsächlich auch bevor
ich mich mit diesem thema auseinander
gesetzt habe und das war auch eine
meiner ersten spuren nicht verfolgt habe
also der die figur des verrückten
professors nämlich weil
eine sache und das zeigt sich eben an
jerry lewis ganz besonders deutlich sehr
sehr nah übereinstimmt auch mit dem mord
und das ist immer so eine gewisse
also die figur verkörpert in jeder
hinsicht so eine gewisse nachlässigkeit
also sie ist meistens
unattraktiv meistens auch ungepflegt
hat und da kommt jetzt der anti
intellektualismus glaube ich sehr gut
zur anschauung hat auch immer so ein
bisschen was entstelltes gesicht also es
ist eine figur wo die zähne zum beispiel
besonders hervor stehen oder wo so
leicht gespielt wird oder also dass
immer sozusagen beide seiten eigentlich
drin sind einerseits ja man irgendwie
biologistisch dem fast schon sozusagen
ein ja gestellt hat
nach sagt auf der einen seite auf der
anderen seite eben auch durch dieses
nachlässige äußere so eine soziale
inkompetenz damit eben ausdrücken möchte
also genau und da
passiert das nati professor eigentlich
sehr prototypisch und wird dann auch
eben vielfach weiter transportiert unter
anderem leben in dann diesen jüngeren
nerd figuren in den team bewiesen sie
schreiben wir spieler 20 jahre vor uns
jahre 1984 sie schreiben sehr
ausführlich über das motiv der rache der
nerds es gibt ja auch einen film dieses
namens halt aus dem jahr 284 was ist
damit eigentlich gemeint und wann kommt
dieses motiv auf also ich hab so ein
bisschen das gefühl dass das motiv auf
jeden fall insofern aufkam oder sich
etabliert natürlich kann es immer sein
dass es auch schon vorher formulierungen
garmann dient dieser begriff angeknüpft
hat mir fällt da jetzt einfach gerade
total spontan einmal wie eben gesprochen
haben über nochmal das motiv des anti
intellektualismus
das ist nämlich 1952 zur wahl war das
glaube ich auch wenn es die münzen und
eisenhower einen ganz wichtigen aufsatz
gab der findung des bochum fehlt einem
rechten intellektuellen der erste
triumph auf der egg hat und damit war
überhaupt nicht gemeint was man jetzt
später dann von der rache des nerds was
man darunter verstand aber das sieht man
auch schon so bestimmte formulierungen
sozusagen
ja die gibt es schon daran kann man
anknüpfen aber 1984 war das ja wo
plötzlich sehr sehr viele
journalistische artikel und auch
sachbücher mit dieser formulierung
gearbeitet haben die rache des nerds und
das buffet damit zusammen dass eben ja
plötzlich also einerseits 1984 das heißt
es gab diese bemühungen irgendwie ja
seitens der medienunternehmen seitens
von journalistin zu beweisen dass es
nicht so wird wie george orwells 1984
und ganz viele haben natürlich den gag
dieses jahres aufgegriffen
und da genau weil natürlich die frage so
ok wo sind wir wo stehen wir in bezug
auf technologie und viele haben sich
dann einfach die figur des nerds
genommen um die aktuellen debatten und
diskurse die mit dieser technologie und
auch der computertechnologie
zusammenhängen anschaulicher zu machen
ist natürlich leichter wenn man fast den
protagonisten hat an dem sich das eben
ganz gut ja zeigen lässt und also die
rache ist insofern eben deshalb
besonders anschaulich weil sie natürlich
so was biografisches hat in bezug auf
den nerd also man kennt eigentlich diese
geschichte schon so ein bisschen aus dem
team usa also der junge ist irgendwie im
teenager alter noch ja wahnsinnig
unbeliebt und wird diskriminiert von den
mitschüler innen und später dann aber
also weil er dann gerade so unbeliebt
war hat ja ganz viel zeit natürlich
seite parierte zu basteln und das sich
mit den themen zu beschäftigen die ihnen
vielleicht dann auch später in dem
sozusagen weiter bringen also dass die
geschichte immer und das erfüllt sich
dann quasi im erwachsenenleben wenn
diese figuren also empfehlen aber
natürlich dann auch reale figuren wie
steve jobs bill gates und so weiter dann
mit ihren erfindungen mit ihren ja
bloßen basteleien plötzlich existenziell
war damals immer das motiv
millionäre werden und die welt verändern
und das ist natürlich ja das ist
natürlich so eine apfel mythos der da
entstanden ist und der sich eigentlich
in dieser formulierung
rache des monats ja dann irgendwie
artikuliert hat und auch heute
eigentlich immer noch so weiter getragen
wird es gibt ja die these dass der nerd
auf rache aus ist wenn man jetzt sehr
streng mit ihm ist ja an die figur das
in cells erinnert also an einen mann der
sich von fraun zurückgesetzt fühlt und
deswegen so eine spezielle form der
hegemonialen männlichkeit für sich
beansprucht und außerdem erinnert eher
an einen geldgeilen neoliberalen
egomanen wie in social network
beispielsweise dargestellt und erinnert
dann auch in dieser form wenn man es
denn weiter spinnt an ein troll ist da
nord insofern inzwischen vollkommen
unzeitgemäß ja also also ich würde
ich würde sagen dass das auf jeden fall
ein gedanke war der mich sehr lange
beschäftigt hat also wo taucht die nerd
figur heute eigentlich auf und auch da
ich hatte es vorher schon angesprochen
es gibt immer gerade den begriff aber es
gibt eben auch diese figur die mit
bestimmten charakteristika und
generation biografischen ration
verbunden ist und bei dem begriff gab es
eigentlich die entwicklung dass wir den
begriff sehr positiv verwenden und zwar
für alles möglich wenn ich erwähnte
frauen das fitnessstudio beispiel und
bei der figur würde ich sagen geht das
ganze in eine andere richtung also die
figur ich stimme 100 prozent zu taucht
tatsächlich auf oder wird angewandt
plötzlich von
subkulturen wie den us amerikanischen
insel zum beispiel ja auch tollen auch
das silicon valley eine das vielleicht
eine nerd variante die ja wie ihren
negativ beurteilen würden und ich glaube
das ja dass man auf jeden fall also ich
versucht sozialen in meinem buch das es
immer wieder versuche gegeben hat
eigentlich diese figur die als
konservatives auch hat die vielleicht
auch dieses motiv der rache hat also
auch durchaus was aggressives in sich
trägt die meistens auch männlich ist und
weiß ist dass die oft versucht wurde
auch zu dekonstruieren von frauen von
people of colour von allen möglichen
menschen die sich sozusagen nicht damit
identifizieren können das ist eigentlich
nie so richtig gelungen ist und man
jetzt eben sieht das dann andere gruppen
sich sehr gut diese figur aneignen
können also wie zum beispiel eben die
insel als die dann eben genauso wie der
ehemaligen hört ja vor ihren computern
sitzen sich dadurch auszeichnen dass sie
keine oder auch dadurch nochmal selbst
definieren dass sie keine frauen kriegen
und so weiter also das passiert das sehe
ich ganz stark und ich frag mich in dem
buch und ich frage mich auch sozusagen
selbst als person schon was macht das
jetzt mit dieser sozial figur also kann
die sozial figur das sozusagen
unbeschadet überstehen oder genau
bekommt der nerd dadurch ja so einen
negativen einschlag der wiederum zur
folge hat dass es für viele
uninteressant ist oder sogar ablehnen es
wert ist sich mit dieser figur noch
weiter zu identifizieren oder diese
figur sogar als auszeichnung zu
verwenden da man irgendwie merkt also
eigentlich passt das jetzt gar nicht und
das passt eigentlich auch nicht nur in
bezug auf also nicht nur nicht in bezug
auf die gruppierungen die sich dieser
figur annehmen sondern natürlich zeigt
das auch dass in dieser figur bestimmte
eigenschaften vorhanden sind die
vielleicht aktuell gesellschaftlich
nicht mehr so gefragt sind ja und das
ist vielleicht auch dieses
einzelgängerischer um das egoistische
auch was wir mit dem nerd teilweise eben
verbinden das ist vielleicht auch eine
figur die nicht mehr unserem aktuellen
wunsch nach empathie zum beispiel
solidarität kollektivität
entspricht also da würde ich schon sagen
merkt man da gerät die figur so ein
bisschen an die grenzen dessen was wir
eigentlich gerade brauchen auch um
gesellschaftliche themen auszuhandeln
ist die figur des nerds ihnen während
sie das buch geschrieben haben
eigentlich immer unsympathischer
geworden
ja
also ehrlich gesagt ja schon es war am
anfang für mich eine sehr sympathische
figur ich bin damit aufgewachsen und
sozialisiert also mit vielen
amerikanischen serien und filmen das war
auch die voraussetzung überhaupt so ein
buch in diesem umfang dann beschreiben
zu können weil man natürlich diese
ganzen serien irgendwie gut kennen muss
und
ja ich bin auf jeden fall mit einem sehr
positiven bild gestartet sagen sie noch
kurz für alle nerds da draußen um welche
serien es sich handelt ach ja also es
beginnt eigentlich steve walker und alle
unter einem dach zum beispiel und endet
natürlich mit big bang theory also all
das sind sie also und wir haben dann
kann tausende dazwischen denn klar ist
ja ich möchte noch eine weibliche note
vielleicht ein klares aufklärerischer
explain the toll also viele sitcoms auch
die mit denen ich eben aufgewachsen bin
und die mir diese figur durchaus
sympathisch haben erscheinen lassen und
sie war ja auch sympathisch und das
genau und natürlich war es für mich dann
auch ja also nicht überraschend
unbedingt und auch nicht unbedingt
traurig aber natürlich so ein bisschen
eine art wie neid empfindet man schon
wenn man eine figur die man sehr gerne
hat ein bisschen verschwinden sieht oder
das gefühl hat dass sie eigentlich ja
bestimmte ansichten bestimmte werte auch
verkörpert die man selber für
unzeitgemäß handelt oder für nicht mehr
erstrebenswert handelt ja es gibt
studien die zu dem ergebnis kommen dass
die bedeutung und bekanntheit des nerds
auf der einen seite und der rückgang von
frauen in der it branche auf der anderen
seite parallel verliefen ist das so
haltbar
ja es ist definitiv so haltbar also man
kann also das beginnt schon damit dass
eigentlich große computer pionieren wie
zb als of nails oder grasshopper also
vor der sozusagen entstehung dieser
figur ja noch ganz selbstverständliche
gut agonisten einfach auch von
informationstechnologien gewesen sind
auch also computer war damals auch eine
berufsbezeichnung die überwiegend
eigentlich von frauen ausgeübt wurde und
ibm also das kann man auch ganz
eindeutig nachrecherchieren hat sich
bestimmten also wenn die stellengesuche
ausgeschrieben haben vor allem an frauen
gerichtet das ändert sich tatsächlich
mit der popularisierung dieser nerd
figur also dass plötzlich ebenso eine
sehr ja so eine sehr männliche figur
eben diese computertechnologie
verkörpert und mit ihr auch eine
arbeitskultur verbunden ist die für
frauen zum beispiel also geheim frauen
jetzt einfach so nicht immer leicht
umzusetzen ist oder eben auch zu
verkörpern ist und insofern genau ging
dann damit also mit wichmann hat dann
erstmal diese ganzen sehr berühmten
männern die natürlich sehen eben auch
diese mörth figur stark geprägt haben
und insofern hatten dann natürlich auch
frauen people of colour auch
trans mensch natürlich sowieso keine wo
model sozusagen in diesem bereich und ja
seitdem nimmt das eigentlich und vor
allem auch bis heute sukzessive ab
obwohl es natürlich immer wieder also
das will ich jetzt auch gar nicht
irgendwie marginalisieren obwohl das
natürlich immer wieder sehr viele
menschen gegeben hat frauen gegeben habe
die auf keiner gegeben hat die sich mit
dieser figur natürlich identifizieren
die auch faktisch nerds sind aber dann
eben in den bestimmten communitys
einfach nicht so anerkannt werden
beobachten sie eigentlich wenn sie
serien gucken oder filme gucken so eine
art bestreben diese figur irgendwie zu
retten indem es einfach mehr weibliche
oder dunkelhäutigen es gibt
ja also es gibt sehr viele figuren die
man vielleicht noch märz nennen kann es
sind oft also es gibt so würde ich sagen
seit zehn jahren so ein bisschen den
versuch den nerd umzuinterpretieren als
eine sehr sehr individualistische figur
die dann vielleicht sogar eher schon
wieder überschneidungen
hat zum freak oder
ja vielleicht auch also die dann aber
vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr unbedingt
wieder die reine klassische mörth figur
ist und insofern weiß ich immer nicht so
genau ob dieser rettungsversuch
sozusagen gelingt oder ob es nicht
einfach dann
ob da nicht einfach wieder neue figuren
entstehen die auch wieder diesen nerd
hinter sich lassen werden da bin ich mir
noch nicht so sicher da muss man glaube
ich auch noch ein bisschen beobachten in
welche richtung das geht und ob die sich
dann wirklich nerds nennen oder nicht
also mein eindruck ist eigentlich eher
nicht obwohl natürlich auch viele
gegenwärtige figuren oder auch ihre
figuren zum beispiel
die figuren aus sechs education zum
beispiel dieser teenager serie natürlich
irgendwie was neuerdings haben aber
vielleicht sind auch eher freaks also
ich weiß gar nicht ob man genau weiß ob
der begriff da noch so tragbar ist oder
ganz normale teenager oder 100 teenager
also auch da generell natürlich auch
diese frage hat mich zu ende meines
buches beschäftigt was heißt es einen
also wie reflektiert benutzen wir
eigentlich sozial figuren und natürlich
immer die tatsache dass ist eine figur
ist und figuren natürlich weil wir sie
natürlich wie menschen denken
geschlechter haben hautfarben haben und
so weiter also wie kann man vielleicht
auch das konzept der sozial figur noch
mal ja irgendwie um verändern umdeuten
uminterpretieren kann es sozusagen
figuren geben die geschlecht los sind
oder die keine konkrete haut war aber
haben also kann man sowas vorstellbar es
ist alles so fragen auf die habe ich
noch so keine antworten aber die haben
sich mir auf jeden fall am ende dieses
buches sehr akut gestellt weil das
vielleicht relevant wäre zumindest für
aktuelle fragen im zusammenhang zum
beispiel mit identitätspolitik
wir müssen einmal nach deutschland
insofern ist der nerd eigentlich hier
angekommen also es gibt schon also man
findet den begriff schon auch so in den
90ern vereinzelt interessanterweise vor
allem eigentlich
bereits aus der us amerikanischen
lifestyle industrie importiert also um
begriff so was wie nerd nerd schick oder
geschick im fashionbereich aber ich sag
mal im gesellschaftlichen
diskursen debatten den journalismus und
so weiter spricht man eigentlich sehr
lange hierzulande eher so vom computer
kit oder technik freak und hat
eigentlich den nerd noch nicht so im
alltagsgebrauch gehabt in den 90ern das
ändert sich eigentlich auch erst anfang
der 2000er jahre und hängt meiner
meine meiner einschätzung nach sehr eng
zusammen mit der mit der etablierung der
piratenpartei in deutschland einerseits
also da haben sehr viele unter anderem
frank schirrmacher damals diesen nerd
begriff fruchtbar gemacht um diese
partei zu bewerten also einerseits zu
charakterisieren andererseits aber auch
zu bewerten und auf der anderen seite
eben mit big bang theory die 2007 eben
zum ersten mal veröffentlicht wurde und
auch hierzulande direkt einfach ein
extremer erfolg war also ich glaube
diese beiden
historischen ereignisse im zusammenhang
mit dem nerd waren eigentlich so die
initiation
ereignisse für die verwendung des
begriffs märz auch in deutschland big
bang theory feuer rasend erfolgreich
sowohl in amerika als auch hier
transportiert aber doch ein relativ
statisches nerd bild oder
absolut also das ist definitiv eine
serie wo ich sagen würde dass sie sehr
klischeehaft ist
bzw ist natürlich eine sitcom und die
sitcom ist natürlich immer auch die muss
auch arbeiten mit stereotypen und mit
klischees und das tut auch diese serie
in
reinform könnte man sagen und es ist
eine serie genauer gesagt die glaube ich
die erfolgreichste sitcom im us amerika
überhaupt ist also ich glaube die haben
sogar für 1 geschlagen also wirklich
wahnsinn ich wahnsinnig erfolgreich und
von daher war es für mich eben auch
überraschend zu sehen dass es seit
einigen jahren
ja auch eine sehr laute kritik an dieser
serie gegeben hat also zu also auch noch
als die serie quasi noch lief aber jetzt
auch im nachhinein doch noch mal sehr
anders bewertet wird weil man natürlich
auch heute ja noch mal mit anderen augen
auf diese art auch von humor auf diese
art von satire auf diese art von
klischees belegt und diese art von
morgen damit meine ich jetzt eben das
zum beispiel bestimmte
bestimmter sexismus oder bestimmte
rassismus der sich durch die nerd immer
auch artikuliert also schlicht auch
einfach deshalb weil sie natürlich
figuren sind die sozial ja da einfach
keine feinsinnigkeit haben und deswegen
natürlich man mit diesem wissen auch zum
ausdruck bringt dass sie das nicht
können irgendwie normal sozial
interagieren
aber dass diese art von humor heute
einfach
niemand mehr so richtig lustig finde
also man sieht einfach an dieser serie
und auch ein bisschen figuren dass ich
da unsere ansprüche sehr stark verändert
haben was nicht unbedingt dazu führen
muss dass man jetzt vielleicht diese
serie per se ja
irgendwie ihre relevanz absprechen muss
natürlich nicht aber man kann schon
sagen dass es vielleicht eine serie ist
die dann zum richtigen zeitpunkt
sozusagen an ein ende gekommen ist
wir müssen noch mal kurz zu bill gates
und steve jobs und den ganzen anhang die
tauchen ja irgendwann auf und sind
sofort so mythisch überhöhten versionen
der ausgangs figur des nerds und beide
haben sich ja immer wieder als
weltverbesserer inszeniert in welchem
verhältnis haben sich von der anti
ästhetisch überformten art wie sie ihnen
jetzt dargestellt haben in film und im
fernsehen und der realen ort
weiterentwickelt oder auch parallel
entwickelt oder inwiefern sind sie sich
eventuell in die quere gekommen
also diese also ich glaube wirklich dass
ist eine der wichtigsten entwicklungen
für die nerd figur gewesen ist dass
plötzlich diese realen personen
auftauchen die daneben
als nerds bezeichneten charakterisiert
wurden und sich auch selbst so
charakterisiert haben wobei man also
sagen muss dieses motiv der
weltverbesserung kommt eigentlich erst
sehr viel später im spiel also wenn man
sich sozusagen die ersten artikel über
diese protagonisten anschaut dann sind
das eigentlich alles dann texte die er
das motiv noch mal betonen dass die
figuren sozusagen exzellente erfolgreich
wurden also eher so aus versehen ja also
waren wir sind ja ein bisschen gebastelt
die sind ihre leidenschaft nachgegangen
und dann ist eben sozusagen die
weltverbesserung ihnen so unterlaufen
das war eigentlich am anfang sehr
starkes motiv und das knüpfte eben ganz
stark an
eigentlich eine frühe ischen nie
ästhetik auch also ich habe so viele
autobiographien gelesen und biografien
gelesen von diesen computer pionieren
und für mich wurde deswegen so eines der
wichtigsten referenzkühler für mich
wurde deshalb auch die legende vom
künstler von ernst gries und otto kurz
aus dem anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts und die haben damals eben
anhand von künstler biografien bestimmte
negative und bestimmte motive vor allem
der künstler figur als genie sozusagen
herausgearbeitet und all diese motive
finden sich wirklich fast eins zu eins
auch bei diesen computer pionieren in
der charakterisierung also das heißt es
sind es wird immer geschrieben dass sie
quasi schon in ihrer kindheit eigentlich
eine besondere
vision arizona division sdd kraft oder
besonders genial waren eben und
überdurchschnittlich begabt und 1000
klassen überspringen konnten und so
weiter und so fort dass sie eben eine
begabung haben die von außen nicht zu
erklären ist dass ihr auserwählte quasi
sind also diese inszenierung form wurden
zu dieser zeit sehr stark angewandt und
dann gibt es aber eben etwas und da
verändert sich dann eben plötzlich auch
wieder die nerd figur und wird zu etwas
das ich dann vielleicht zu den sieg in
berlin
also da etabliert sich quasi diese
computer nerd figur
die sich ausdrückt im job skates und co
und natürlich denkt man danach immer
auch schon dieses erfolgs motiv mit und
dieses erfolgs motiv wird dann für
figuren wie den sieg in berlin 40 sehr
dominant also wenn man sich dann
wiederum figuren anschauen wie mark
zuckerberg zum beispiel denen die haben
dann nicht mehr dieses motiv das die
existenz sozusagen erfolgreich geworden
sind sondern ganz im gegenteil die sind
dann eben diese sehr
kalkül
betriebenen
neoliberalen figuren die eigentlich
gerade bei denen das motiv der rache am
anfang steht und die wenn man sich filme
anschaut über mark zuckerberg the social
network zum beispiel die ja die ganzen
erfindungen die sie tun natürlich nur
machen um ja keine ahnung frauen 1 rhein
zwischen oder eben ja finanziell
erfolgreich damit zu werden also da
genau verändert sich dann die figur ganz
stark in so eine richtung wo quasi das
motiv der weltverbesserung eigentlich zu
so einer floskel wird die aber nicht
mehr gefüllt ist und inhalt als sie
freunden und kollegen erzählten dass sie
ein buch über nerds schreiben hat man
sie immer wieder gefragt ob sie sich
selbst für einen nerd halten wie haben
sie darauf geantwortet
nein also ich war also ich habe nein
geantwortet weil ich ehrlicherweise
immer überrascht und zwar einerseits
eben weil man damit ja immer so ein
bisschen unterstellt dass man irgendwie
sich dann als kulturwissenschaftlerin
damit identifiziert das liegt mir aber
total fern und das war auch wirklich
nicht die motivation für dieses buch und
auf der anderen seite weil ich jetzt
zumindest dem stereotyp erst mal so gar
nicht entsprechen also klar ich bin eine
frau und irgendwie auch interessiert an
mode und ein team die man jetzt erstmal
mit dem nerd nicht so nach sagt aber
gleichzeitig ist natürlich meine these
und insofern muss ich mich auch selber
ein nerd nennen dass alle mittlerweile
sind das heißt ja dass alle pessimisten
die jenigen die eine bestimmte
leidenschaft verfolgen die eine
bestimmte
kennerschaft in einem bestimmten bereich
ausbilden ja sich selbst nennen und auch
als apps bezeichnet werden können und in
diesem sinne bin ich natürlich auch
temporär mal jetzt ein nerd oder
wenn ich mein nächstes thema angeht bin
ich dann vielleicht ein xy wird also das
ist durchaus möglich und insofern genau
und trifft diese figur auch auf mich zu
aber genau also dem stereotyp würde ich
jetzt immer sagen entspreche ich eher
nicht ja letzte frage unter all den
unmöglichen nerds welcher ist an ihr
liebster
also mein absoluter lieblingsort ist
clarissa aus der serie klares explain
the door also eine weibliche werden
sozusagen und diese serie fand klar oder
wurde ausgestreut glaube ich ende der
90er jahre und war für mich als teenager
wahnsinnig einprägsam weil das eben eine
frauenfigur gezeigt hat die
ja also nicht optisch nötig ist aber von
ihrem verhalten natürlich nötig ist hier
ist also programmiert selber
computerspiele sie hat einen eigenen
computer in ihrem kinderzimmer sozusagen
sie hat männliche freunde ohne dass es
eine romantische oder sexuelle beziehung
ist also sie ist einfach in jeder
hinsicht als norden sozusagen ein finde
ich ein vorbild gewesen ohne dass man ja
dass der youtube dafür hätte bemühen
müssen märz eine pop kultur geschichte
ist bei ch beck erschienen kostet 16
euro 95 und ist unbedingt lesenswert
vielen dank anne kathrin code ich danke
ihnen
in den schoß und auf unserer seite
faz.net / bücher - podcast bücher mit
finden sie weiterführende hinweise wenn
sie fragen oder anmerkungen haben können
sie mir gerne schreiben die
e-mail-adresse lautet bücher - podcast
faz.de bücher mit sie können unseren
podcast auch abonieren bleiben und ihm
ein sternchen verpassen vielen dank fürs
zuhören und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]